times stories don't become outdated they
simply re-emerge when
certain political entities need them
this summer a huge scandal broke out
when it was alleged by u.s
media that russia was paying bounties to
the taliban for the killing of u.s
soldiers
though no concrete evidence to
substantiate that was ever provided
though many have probably forgotten the
story it has now
resurfaced conveniently as senators are
pushing their russia
bounty response act not later 90 days
after the date of the enactment of this
act
the secretary of state shall submit to
the appropriate congressional committees
and leadership
a strategy on how the united states will
diplomatically counter
russian influence in the region of south
and central asia
now the bill would prohibit all property
transactions as well as entry to the
united states by vladimir putin
his closest aides along with many
prominent political and business
individuals in russia quite a stiff bill
it goes after their family members and
all the major supporters of this bill
happen to be democrats they say they
want to send a message
to the russian president and apparently
his american counterpart
congress has an obligation to step in
and act
putin is emboldened by president trump's
capitulation
and is increasing his aggressive
behavior which includes
putting bounties on american troops the
lives of american service members are at
stake
i urge senators on both sides of the
aisle to join us in protecting our
service members
and sending a strong message to putin
now it's not all about sanctioning
putin or criticizing donald trump there
happens to be
quite a bit of money involved there is
authorized to be appropriated 50 million
dollars for each of fiscal years 2021
through 2026
for programming that provides rewards to
individuals
who provide information on russian
bounties against united states armed
forces
an additional 30 million dollars will go
to
combat the influence of russia in
central and southern asia
but the bill has still more goals in the
minds of its sponsors
the russia bounty response act is
necessary to protect americans
against putin's bounty driven killing
and trump's reprehensible inaction
strong sanctions and other steps will
give putin the only incentive he
understands
hitting him and his surrogates where it
hurts so it's anti-russia
anti-trump and it promotes democracy
but does it really have much to do with
the lives of american soldiers
that remains a question i wouldn't
expect any clear compelling evidence to
be made to support these claims well
this illustrates the opaque nature of
the intelligence community
namely it could be claimed that by doing
so sources and methods would be revealed
or that it would compromise an ongoing
investigation ultimately i don't think
the rewards will be paid and that's
because that's not the real intent
behind the bill here
it's a matter of public spectacle
regardless of those who support or
oppose the trump presidency
i would actually question the timing of
this given how close we are to the
general election
provided that this bill passes the house
they'll be voted down along
in the senate along party lines the
republican members of the senate
have tied their careers and fortunes to
the trump presidency
to call under the question the
president's integrity would ultimately
undermine
their favorability among registered
republican voters
in my opinion
you